في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع، سألت بيث سانر،
نائبة مدير المخابرات الوطنية السابقة
في الولايات المتحدة، عما تعتقد أن
الرئيس بايدن يمكن أن يفعله بشكل
مختلف فيما يتعلق
بإسرائيل. وأعتقد أن أحد الأشياء التي
يمكننا القيام بها بالتأكيد هو أن نحدد بحزم شديد
ما لا تستطيع إسرائيل فعله  في
الضفة الغربية لأن هذا هو الشيء
الذي سينفجر في وجوهنا والذي
يجعل حل الدولتين
مستحيلاً. نقطة ساندرز
مهمة لأنه مع تركيز العالم
على
غزة، الأعضاء الرئيسيون في
حكومة نتنياهو والحكومة الائتلافية التي
شكلها  أعضاء رئيسيون في تلك الحكومة
يلقون النار على النيران في
الضفة الغربية وفي إسرائيل في
صحيفة حاريتس الإسرائيلية يوم الاثنين من هذا الأسبوع،
دعا كاتب العمود في قصيدة بشارات اثنين من
أعضاء حكومة نتنياهو
لاستغلال هجمات حماس.
واستخدام الهجمات
لتعزيز أجندتهم العنصرية
المناهضة للعرب،
فلنبدأ من الضفة الغربية كما
اقترح سنر أنه ينبغي علينا أن نفعل ذلك مع
وزير المالية الإسرائيلي بتسلئيل سموتريش
سموتريتش، وهو متعصب بغيض مناهض للعرب،
وهو سياسي يميني متطرف في
ائتلاف نتنياهو وقد
صلاحيات واسعة النطاق فيما يتعلق بالقضايا المدنية في
الضفة الغربية تشير تقارير هارز إلى أنه منذ 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)،
قُتل أكثر من 170 فلسطينيًا في
اشتباكات مع إسرائيليين في جميع أنحاء
الضفة الغربية، ويرجع ذلك الآن إلى عام 2005 عندما
كانت إسرائيل تنسحب من غزة، وتم
اعتقال سموتريتش من قبل
أجهزة الأمن الإسرائيلية.  تم القبض على شينب سموي
للاشتباه في التخطيط
لهجمات إرهابية، وتم احتجازه من قبل شنب بيت لمدة
ثلاثة أسابيع، وكان يشتبه في تخطيطه
لإغلاق الطرق العامة الرئيسية والإضرار
بالبنية التحتية، وذلك وفقًا لما ذكرته
صحيفة يوت أكانو الإسرائيلية الكبرى في عام
2019، النائب السابق لرئيس  ووصف شينب
سموتريتش بأنه
إرهابي يهودي، وهذا بحسب
القناة
13 الإسرائيلية، والآن ينفي سموتريتش تلك المزاعم التي
ذكر أنه فخور بدوره في
معارضة طرد إسرائيل من غزة،
مشيرًا إلى أنه تم إطلاق سراحه دون
توجيه أي تهم ضده
وفقًا لتقرير من  التايمز أوف
إسرائيل الآن بشارات يكتب في هاريتز يوم
الاثنين من هذا الأسبوع أن اقتباس سموتريتش
يستغل الكارثة التي حلت
بالبلاد كفرصة لنهب
الضفة الغربية، وقد بدأ ERS الذين يشاركون
أيديولوجيته المسيحية في
تنفيذ خططهم للتطهير  منطقة
سكانها الفلسطينيين
غير مقتبسة كما هو الحال في هذا المشهد الذي ترى فيه
مستوطنين إسرائيليين مسلحين متعصبين
متطرفين يضايقون الفلسطينيين
ويحدثون الفوضى في
الضفة الغربية ثم هناك وزير
الأمن القومي إيتمار بنير يقتبس
فور سماعه
بهجمات حماس الإجرامية بشارات يكتب بيناف
كان يدعو إلى تكملة لأعمال
الشغب العربية اليهودية عام 2021 من أجل التهام
ما تبقى من الديمقراطية الإسرائيلية، بما في
ذلك الميليشيات المسلحة
التابعة لبنير التي تتجول في
شوارع تل أبيب، واقتبس
فكرة الشرطة التي تعمل بجد لاعتقال
مدرس التربية المدنية الدكتور مير بي بارين  للمشاركات
على فيسبوك التي تعارض عمليات الجيش الإسرائيلي
في غزة ولإظهار
التعاطف مع معاناة الفلسطينيين،
بالطبع، أهداف بن جاف الأولى التي
يكتبها للمواطنين العرب في إسرائيل
الذين تعرضوا للمضايقات واتهموا
واعتقلوا، لا يقتصر الأمر على
إراقة دماء البشر فحسب، بل أيضًا  هو
دماء الديمقراطية الإسرائيلية أو ما
تبقى منها حولها فرقة مجنونة
ترقص بفرح مقولة بينير
أعلنت الحرب على المجتمع العربي
ولم تنطق كلمة واحدة من النقد
من قبل التيار الإسرائيلي الرئيسي
ضد هذا المشهد المخزي الذي
لم يقتبس بالأمس بن  نشر غافيير هذا
الفيديو وهو يتفاخر بكيفية
تلقي إرهابيي حماس، اقتبس
الشروط الأكثر صرامة لثمانية
إرهابيين مكبلي الأيدي في زنزانة مظلمة، أسرة حديدية، مراحيض في
حفرة في الأرض، حيث قام
المواطن الإسرائيلي جيل ديكمان بتغريد اثنين من
الوزير بن جافير يقتبس إيتمار أنا
أتوسل  ابن عمه الآن في يد
كاماس، لقد تم اختطافه، ابن عمه،
كلماتك عن الزنزانة المظلمة، الثقب في
الأرض، الأصفاد والإذلال المذل
يعرضها لخطر حقيقي،
كل تغريدة لك هي مباراة تحرق
قلوب عائلاتنا.  أنا أتوسل إلى
إيتامار، هناك إسرائيليون هناك
حياتهم وموتهم في يد
لسانك، من فضلك توقف عن
الاقتباس ولكن التفكير في مثل هذه الأشياء
لا يبدو حقًا أنه طريقة بن غاب،
فهو عضو عنصري علني ومعاد للعرب ينتمي إلى
أقصى اليمين المتطرف.
الحزب الذي انضم إليه نتنياهو لتشكيل
ائتلافه، يجب أن نعرف أن آراء بن جاف الدنيئة
ليست مفاجئة حتى عام 2020.
كان لدى بينير صورة في منزله في
بارو
غولدشتاين. بارو غولدشتاين هو
إرهابي يهودي قتل 29
مصليًا فلسطينيًا في الحرم الإبراهيمي عام 1994.
مذبحة عام 2015 حضر بنير
حفل زفاف سيء السمعة من الكراهية في
الضفة الغربية في حفل زفاف الكراهية هذا،
تم الاحتفال بقتل الفلسطينيين بما في ذلك
مقتل
رضيع فلسطيني، إنه
مريض الآن في يناير، يبدو أنه
قبل مائة عام، لكنه كان 10 سنوات فقط
قبل أشهر سألت رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو عن هذين العنصريين المناهضين للعرب، هؤلاء
المتطرفين في
حكومته، لقد قمت بتعيين بعض
الأفراد وشخصيات مثيرة للجدل ليست
جزءًا من حزبك، بما في ذلك
القوميين المتطرفين، بيتل سموتريتش وإيتامار
بن جافير، لقد انضموا إلى المجموعة ولم
أنضم إليها  هم على حق وأنا أوجه السياسة التي
أحكمها، لقد وضعت يدي على
عجلة القيادة وصدقني أنه
سيكون اتجاهًا جيدًا SMR أطلق على
نفسه اسم الفاشي كاره للمثليين واقترح
زواج المثليين مثل سفاح القربى
النائب السابق آه مدير شينب  قال إنه
إرهابي يهودي حاول
تنظيم حدث عندما كان
الانسحاب من غزة جاريًا وفي ذلك اليوم
كان يقول إنه كان
يطرح نظريات المؤامرة الفظيعة هذه،
لا بد أنك رأيت هذا بشأن
الخفاش اللامع  واغتيال رابين،
أعني أن هؤلاء يبدون
كأفراد متطرفين إلى حد ما، نعم حسنًا، الكثير من الناس
يقولون الكثير من الأشياء عندما لا يكونون في
السلطة ويخففون من حدة أنفسهم نوعًا ما
عندما يصلون إلى السلطة، وهذا هو
الحال بالتأكيد هنا  أنظر أه أنا
أه أنا المسيطر على الحكومة وأنا
مسؤول عن سياساتها والسياسات
معقولة وهم
مسؤولون وما زالوا كذلك
ولم يعبثوا بأنفسهم بمجرد
وصولهم إلى السلطة لقد
فعلوا ذلك  وإذا كانت يد نتنياهو على
عجلة القيادة، فإن السؤال المطروح لنتنياهو هو
هل يقف إلى جانب تطرف هذين
الوزيرين لأن الأمر لا يقتصر على
وجود سموتريش وبينير
في الحكومة الإسرائيلية فحسب، بل أيضًا على
السياسات التي يطبقونها في
الغرب.  الضفة الغربية وإسرائيل، والتي تتعارض بشكل واضح
مع الصورة التي تصورها إسرائيل
للعالم الغربي في هذه اللحظة الحاسمة
من وجود إسرائيل والتي يجب
تحديها